hey how's it going my name is beautifu
welcome to black desert character
creation this game has absolutely
stunning character creation people are
making anything from Michael Jackson to
other various celebrities and they look
so accurate now let's do even better
gotta close the door because it's about
to get dirty honestly like this MMO
looks [ __ ] awesome if I was a
teenager again I'd be over all over this
[ __ ]
like you can be a kawaii animu girl I
think that's a good selling point but
that's not why we're here we're here to
create the sexiest character alive let's
start without God he's ugly oh my lord
that is a type of hair oh okay you can
do that you can adjust the spikes that's
I've always said that's a good thing oh
my god you can customize everything this
is like customization porn oh he's so
cute he's so sexy
now let's go deeper now that's the kind
of mustache that will get you the ladies
no eyebrows don't eat him oh so now we
can press this parts on his face to drag
it the way we oh my god I want him to
look like he ate a lobster and he's
allergic that's what we're going for
here
you
Oh oh you're so high ah yeah oh my god
he looks like a Klingon
oh we're getting there
oh my god dude I'm so sorry about your
face hahaha oh yes oh it looks like a
pineapple pineapple man my hero when you
see the booty ah when you forget to pull
out
I'm 12 don't worry about it oh my god
this pineapple just went sour Jesus
Christ when Sasuke leaves Naruto
standby expression Oh
oh no God please a my prayer a pouch
tell me I'm beautiful Oh God
I means are just reaction faces are just
being born as we speak you did watch and
that's our oh we have it even customize
the body yet we haven't even gone to the
body
pineapple man it's very short but
buffest [ __ ] individual control oh we
can change his pose yeah bad up a man
don't take [ __ ] for no boy oh god I love
him so much I really want to play this
game now just so I can play with
pineapple man alright so that was
pineapple man I [ __ ] saved
let's do with a girl let's create a hot
babe someone for pineapple man to be a
man to if you know what I mean now look
at this gorgeous
anime babe alright this girl has never
ever been in battle let's get real here
but lights let's see if we can make her
ugly I feel like it's not possible like
you can even drag the hair I know look
how much you can customize it's
ridiculous oh my god oh my god okay we
that know that's racist
that's definitely racist I did not
select that this game is really why I
should not be a plastic surgeon
I mean she's not so bad okay oh God yeah
you're y'all take I'll take that one
back never mind take it in back again a
radda radda radda radda radda radda brat
don't tell much oh my god
yeah that's a nice tattoo oh god we can
cook we can really make the right titty
bigger than the left titty finally a
game that properly does that
oh oh hey hey can we just have like a
before and after shot I feel like that's
necessary should we try one serious one
where I just try and make myself I think
that'd be kind of cool okay this is our
template oh yeah that looks good
well my beard is clearly not in the game
it's really getting there it's [ __ ]
weird does it look the same that's
awesome I mean it's not perfect by any
means but this is pretty [ __ ] cool I
gotta say I'm super impressed now
obviously we need to add a little bit of
more yep that's accurate there we go
actually I always skip leg day there we
go that's better
I didn't even adjust the eyes on
pineapple man wait if I gotta do that oh
my god pineapple man what the [ __ ]
all right so that is the character
creation - black desert it's free to
check out if you want to do it yourself
send me your creations at hashtag black
boots I probably should have thought of
that before I said it either way thank
you so much for watching I really
enjoyed this I hope you enjoyed it as
well thank you for leaving a like if you
did and as always stay awesome right
yeah sexy haircut I don't know how many
times I've asked Marzia - to change your
hairstyle into Goku
you